zwar habe ich mit diesem befehl einen
riesigen turm voller schafe gemacht und
wenn ihr mal genau darauf achtet die
verändern andauernd ihre farbe wieso
laufen bewegt sich hier meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zur ersten
folge minecraft command ich habe an
einer facts folge einfach mal oder alte
mehreren sechs folgen immer wieder ganz
ganz viele kommando coco capcom auf
deutsch wir werden als sex immer richtig
oft command zugesendet und command
eigentlich kein effekt sondern
irgendwelche sachen und command sind
quasi unendlich man kann alles möglich
in command reinpacken so dass es
irgendwie cool ist deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache eine folge minecraft
command und wenn ihr sagt okay ich hab
da bock drauf machen mehr commands dass
es eben so ein bisschen wie diese serie
soll das einmal pro woche auch eine
minecraft command serie kommt wo ich
fünf coole commands vorstelle dann zeigt
es mir auf jeden fall mit einer
bewertung und das zeigt mir dann ob ihr
davon mehrere folgen die sache ist also
ich hab jetzt schon 5 1 vorbereitet wir
fangen auch direkt mit dem ersten
command an allerdings mail zusenden
wollt dann nicht über die kommentare
sondern bitte in der beschreibung findet
ihr oben einen link bit.ly / comand aps
c oder irgendwie so den findet ihr oben
in der beschreibung und da könnt ihr
einfach draufklicken und da müsst ihr
euch anmelden sondern könnte einfach den
commander eingeben und euren namen und
wie er genannt werden wollte und dann
ist eventuell im nächsten video dran
aber wir fangen dort als allererstes
wenn wir einen command machen möchten
ist natürlich wie geht ein / gfp oder et
konnt rafter halt command block und dann
bekommen wir einen befehl blog den
setzen wir erst mal hin der ist später
wichtig wenn man ganz lange befehle hat
für den anfang braucht mit den erst mal
nicht nämlich der erste command / samen
skeleton bälle willi wällering die
spider damit kann man nicht einen spider
jockey erschaffen und es ist blöd dass
jetzt tages soll wenn wir mal unter dem
baum beck geht fängt der jeden moment an
zu brennen
später kommen kommt kommt kommt ich gebe
mal eben time satellite ein und zwar
kennt ihr diesen befehl wahrscheinlich
schon aus nach sechs serien zwar kann
man den nämlich um minden und zwar das
cool ist damit kann man nicht nur in
spider job machen sondern ich kann doch
mal eingeben skeleton hierhin und ich
kann hier vorne einfach mal beide jetzt
bin ich hier am anfang ein paar tipp
gebe ich hier vorne mich einfach mal
spyder ein und zwar ist es dann eine
spinne die ein skelett reiter ich
manchmal doch jeder tageszeit tag nicht
das ist hier das ist total winkel alles
machen wir ab wie das geht dann könnte
ich rein theoretisch auch mal schief
eingeben der ein schaf reitet und zwar
soll das eine kuh sag ich mal dann gebe
ich da keinen unterschied da haben wir
doch eine kleine crew auf einem schaf
und das geil an diesem befehl deshalb
man kann ihn uns beinahe jockey spawn
sondern einfach so totale missgeburten
einfach guckt euch das mal dachten dass
wir auf jeden fall befehl nummer eins
das man nicht nur mit diesem befehl
einen spider jockey machen kann sondern
auch einen
missgeburten ding übrigens findet ihr
unten in der beschreibung die befehle
immer ganz unten verlinkt damit ihr die
selber mal ausprobieren könnt aber wir
kommen fehler nummer zwei ist das
gleiche prinzip allerdings sieht das aus
wie eine prinzessin und zwar gebe ich
dass hier einst am and gas trading idea
gar nicht so okay weil der gast einfach
gestorben ich glaube ich gebe das ganze
hier einfach noch mal ein hier überleben
die auf jeden fall und zwar sieht das
ganze aus wie eine prinzessin und zwar
ist ein gas der einen giganten reiten
dass wir sie auch die solche haare die
im wind wehen
das ist so affig guckt euch das war
anders kann davon muss ich jetzt einfach
mal ein screenshot machen das sieht ja
mal so behindert habe sei also gar guck
mal der tiere gigant da unten steht
immer noch in der wand fest und diese
ganzen behinderten missgeburten da unten
leben ob man also dieser befehl wird in
minecraft forum immer als princess
command abgespeichert weil oder
abgestempelt weil das so aussieht als
wären das die haare von dem kopf und so
und seine prinzessin und so sieht ganz
cool aus eigentlich ganz witzig aus ist
quasi vom vom command her sehr ähnlich
wie der erste allerdings hat echt extrem
wird hier mit diesem riding irgendwas
kann man richtig viel machen habe ich
glaube ich jetzt sogar noch einem staat
also wie kommen mahnt nummer drei ist
mich wieder einreiht in command
allerdings nicht mit lob und mops
sondern was ich ja auch letztes mal am
fag zweimal gefragt hatte ob das auch
mit entities geht und zwar kann man hier
mit einem flugzeug erschaffen mehr oder
weniger und zwar sammeln mein card und
das wird geleitet von einem schicken und
dann sehen wir schon da ist ein flugzeug
und das land jetzt so ganz langsam weil
das mic hat fährt eine beliebige
richtung und das hühnchen fliegt jetzt
einfach so runter das sieht aus wie so
ein flugzeug was einfach jetzt karten
landet mit den flügeln alter so affig
und guck mal das witzige ist auch das
geht immer weiter also wenn das jetzt
hier gegen flieht guckt thema bayern
münchen jetzt das hühnchen hier acom
jetzt jetzt gehen runter kommt dass ich
die ganze zeit auf trab letztes mal
müssen runter und jetzt gehts nämlich
wieder in diese richtung hier
weiterkommen kommen nein ich mache den
weg frei
und dann hilft das eben warum sowieso
ein behindertes stück scheiße alte ochs
oder wenn ich das hühnchen nicht bewegt
geht es mit dem main hat immer noch
weiter und das fli quasi immer so ein
bisschen über die luft und es wird
geleitet von diesem münchen
man sieht super das hat jetzt mal nicht
wieder hier eingeben beispielsweise dann
reitet er ja okay das muss man
eigentlich schon von einer etwas höher
gelegene position machen übrigens habe
ich extra das ist so bei testgelände
dass sich alles so ein bisschen die
streu tischen ort nicht ganz cool
eigentlich und damit kann man quasi
sollen ein flugzeug erschaffen und jetzt
meine lieben freunde kommen wir zu den
richtig richtig geil gefehlt zwar kann
ich mit diesem befehl einen creepers
tonnen und zwar dieser krieg ist powered
1 allerdings hat er einen explosions
radius von 100 jetzt einfach mal
unterdrücke bekomme ich diesen krieg und
ich kann diese krippe hier anzünden und
ihr seht schon es ist alles kaputt
es war vielleicht nicht ganz so klug
meine ganze welt ist jetzt einfach schon
mal hier im eimer na ja ich würde sagen
ob im zweiten krieg bei ihren namen
creeper parteien sex clown radios ja
kommen 150 kann man dem ergebnis sind
bei dem er an und ruckelt und hallo
klima.de macchiato oder kennzahlen das
einfach auch guck mal hier ist unser
flugzeug noch am start
oder es kann einfach sein dass 100 auch
wichtig das höchste sich geht nochmal
150 einmal schauen ob er hier schaden
macht hier macht er keinen schaden was
ist denn wenn ich mal 110 eingebe gibt
das 110 funktioniert 110 funktioniert
noch okay all das ist ja echt krass da
kann man halt einfach so mit diesem
kommenden creeper erzeugen die
explosions radius im umkreis von 110
blöcken hat deswegen sie doch hier sind
die bäume teilweise mit abgeschnitten
und nicht nur das unter ihm und jetzt
quasi eine kugel gemacht worden und er
hat alles kaputt gemacht und das war
command nummero 4,06 brauche ich jetzt
nämlich diesen command block und zwar
wenn ich mir dann eben noch mal ein
bisschen redstone dass das ganze hier
bauern kann und zwar hier noch einen
schalter so das kommt dann mal eben hier
rum und dann gebe ich in diesen command
blog dass hier ein nicht die ganzen
klammern sondern das ist einfach ein
extrem langer befehl wenn ich mir hier
so ein bisschen zurück seht ihr schon
das ist einfach dass dies eigentlich das
einzige was er braucht nur zwei dinge
die schief custom made visible 1 custom
namen gap das heißt custom games sowie
mit einem tag wenn ich jetzt mal fertig
clique unterdrücke seht ihr schon
fakt die ganze schafe sterben nein nein
nein die haben doch hier oben geht
weiter ok kumpel zwar habe ich mit
diesem befehl einen riesigen turm voller
schafe gemacht und wenn ihr mal genau
darauf achtet die verändern andauernd
ihre farbe wieso laufen bewegt sind
der job bewegt sich erläuft weg scheiße
was ist wenn ich den turm mal rein
hypothetisch gesehen hier runterschubsen
hallo hallo bin gefahren ein herz und
ein echt extrem aber schaut man das ist
richtig cool die verändern die ganze
zeit ihre farbe es wäre einfach noch
viel krasser wenn die einfach da nur die
shops michael die ganze zeit runter er
ich muss geld jetzt dieser turm auf
einmal laufen kann jedenfalls ihr wisst
ja mit job unterstrich kann man ein
schaf machen was die farbe verändern
wenn man dann einfach den befehl
eingeben den ich gerade ein gegeben hat
bzw den ihr in der in der beschreibung
findet kann man sich so einen riesigen
turm machen mit ganz vielen schafen tier
zusammen und die verändern alle andauern
ihre farben und weniger ins zentrum dass
ihr die am besten dass sie die farben
verändern wir nicht davon ab dass unsere
schweine dass unsere scharf achte und
der turm ist auf jeden fall
der ist schon extrem hoch und ich würde
sagen wenn er dieses unter scharfe das
ist so ein starkes abkommen das müssen
einmal hüpfen hier und nimmt den ganzen
turm mit er das ist richtig kraft würde
allerdings auch sagen meine lieben
freunde damit war es das für die erste
folge minecraft command sorry falls die
kommission einig waren dass man einfach
weil ich die jetzt selber aussuchen
musste wenn ihr allerdings coole konzept
in der beschreibung findet sich ein
formular das könnt ihr einfach ausfüllen
und medien wie command zu senden was
kann ja auch ein theoretisch sein dass
er sagt wir wollen keine nächste folge
der minecraft command serie dann einfach
den daumen runter gehen wenn allerdings
boca für sowas nochmal mache einfach so
ein bisschen rum experimentiere dann
freue ich mich über jeden daumen hoch
und jeden netten kommentar und dieser
turm kommt auf mich zu irgendwie und
auch man ich würde auf jeden fall sagen
wir sehen uns in einem nächsten video
wieder zu hüllen